okay origami is impressive but what do
you do with all those paper cranes once
you're finished our next inventor Ryo
Mishima makes them dance
this is futuristic robotic origami only
in Japan you may have heard of the Funky
Chicken
well how about the crazy crane this clip
has well over a million views but how do
the birds get down on the dance floor
the key to making these cranes boogies
is magnets they are permanent magnets on
the feet of the cranes and there are
also electromagnets underneath the dance
floor and that consists of a coil of
wire wrapped around an iron core when
you connect a current to this coil a
magnetic field is created around it this
means you can switch those magnets on or
off the central crane has a 5x5 grid of
electromagnets underneath and so they're
actually able to attract the feet of the
crane so it appears to move and if they
do it in the right order they can
actually make the crane turn around
dance it's amazing great paper one more
thing that can dance better than me